we're building a hacker drone it's a
real experiment we assembled the Drone
using these parts
now let's hack into their computer we
fly up to the window launch the attack
and it all happens in seconds and now we
have access to everything our device
finds vulnerabilities in the nrf24l chip
this chip is in the Logitech u-0007
adapter this is how we take control of
the computer's input wireless devices
what did we use to create the attack
device the crazy radio PA USB adapter
with an antenna used as a controller we
upgrade the crazy radio PA to make it a
hacking device a few lines of python
code to make the adapter send commands
like a keyboard we also use a mini
Raspberry Pi zero that we have
programmed and we add a battery the
total weight is enough for the Drone to
lift it the Drone is ready to hack see
the full video in the pinned comment